all right Tabitha yes Tabitha uh would
you grow up where are you from
originally
Harlan County
and uh tell me about your family growing
up you had Mom and Dad uh yeah I had a
mom a dad uh my dad
I don't he they're both passed away but
um my dad was an alcoholic and my mom
worked hard trying to raise us three
kids I've got a brother and a sister
how far are you in school
um I had I quit my 12th grade year but I
went and got my GED before my class
graduated okay
how would you describe your childhood in
general it was a happy childhood didn't
have a lot but you know overall we was
happy kids
mom and dad did everything they could
for us it's a beautiful part of the
country to grow up in oh I love it here
yeah
I have went to uh I've visited Florida I
visited Tennessee I've visited other
places but there's no place like home I
get homesick
tell me about uh your life now you you
have children I got two kids
um my oldest one she's 23 and then my
youngest son he's uh 15. he'll be 16
this year I got three grandkids the
oldest one is uh four and then the
youngest one just turned one and you're
raising your kids now you're raising
your children now
um yeah um I've always raised my kids my
daughter don't live with me she's got
her own family but my son does right and
you you're married
um no we've been together 15 uh well
yeah about 14 15 years but we not we're
not married
and who's the father of your children
um Kenneth Marlowe is my daughter's dad
and then Shelby Shell is my son's dad
would you care to share the story you
told me about Shelby yeah um he um he's
the one that got accused of killing
um Ronnie King the mayor of Beverage how
many years ago was that
um
oh my goodness I'd say maybe seven or
eight years just roughly
um that was after me and him had split
up and I've worked really hard on my son
to make sure he's not got his jeans
that's right so your son is doing fine
now he's oh yeah yeah he's throbbing
he's 15.
yeah he's a good boy he really is ain't
been in trouble
um he's the typical teenager he's mouthy
but he ain't never been in no serious
trouble anything like that I'm very
blessed with both of my kids
and you're going through something now
personally that is a struggle for you
right yeah uh was diagnosed with uh at
first it was stage three breast cancer
and now it's uh stage four breast cancer
because it's in my bones
yeah they said life expectancy is five
years but my doctor said that he does
have a patient that's walking around
that's got the same thing I do uh 10
years later so I'm going to be one of
them people good for you
I think just having that hope yeah and
drive to be there for your kids or for
your family yes my kids and my grandkids
that's what's keeping me going and
that's how my mom was too it seems like
once those kids told her that you know
it's okay if you're tired and need to go
home it's okay it seems like that's when
she she passed I think she hung on for
us and her grandkids
[Music]
how many years ago was it you were
diagnosed
um just may just recently just a couple
months ago oh really yeah so what do you
what do you go through emotionally
finding out that you have stage three or
stage four cancer oh it's hard
um I'm trying to keep up a positive
outlook because I know God's Gonna he's
gonna be the one to help me through this
but it's hard thinking that I might be
leaving my son and my grandkids my
daughter I wanted to see my daughter
walk across that stage to get her
diploma and she quit school on me when
she turned 18. so my son promised me
that he would do it so I hope that I'm
here to watch him get that diploma
did she followed after her mom yeah she
did but she didn't get her GED I got
mine
and you're are you going through pain
now because of this or
um
that's where most I think they said
that's where most of it is in my bones
my hip will give me a lot of trouble so
the breast cancer is spread to your
bones yeah
yeah it gives me trouble but that's
about it right now the port in my neck
has came it's not kinked but it has
curved and that causes pain right now
um my next uh treatment is going to be
toasty chemotherapy yes and after that I
think we're going to talk about moving
it to the other side
what do you go through with your chemo
treatments
um it was six hours long
but where they found out it's in my
bones they took one of the chemos away I
was on two different antibodies and two
different chemos they took one of them
away so now my it's a four hours long
I've had two the first one made me real
sick for like a week I would stay sick
but this last time
um praise God I didn't get sick none at
all
how old are you now 41 41 and your
belief in God helps you I can't yeah and
I think he's going to be the one to help
me get rid of it because just because
there ain't no cure down here don't mean
there ain't no cure up there that he
can't do
what what perspective has how has it
changed your your view of of your time
here on Earth
do you have this diagnosis
um I always know life was short
but I never realized how short it was
until now and you know you just keep
thinking am I going to have time am I
going to have time it's
it's hard I try
I try not to let my old man and my kids
hear me talk like that but it is hard
you have friends that have gone through
similar things or is there
my daughter's aunt great aunt which I
call her my aunt who
um she had the breast cancer
oh I'd say about 18 years ago and the
same breast had it removed they're going
to remove mine after chemo
and she survived the
she had open heart surgery a mechanical
aorta valve
last year at the mechanical valve got
stopped up
and they was about they had her put to
sleep going to do surgery in UK she had
a 20 chance of living out of this
surgery
the doctors was coming down to cut her
open and looked up and seen something in
the x-rays maybe but realized that it
was gone but in one day one day God had
taken from her and she didn't have to
have the surgery and she's still around
yeah
let's hope for something like that for
you too yep but it was the lady that I
was with in everything yeah
and do you
have do you look back at your life and
wish you had done things differently or
wish you had done things that you never
got a chance to
maybe do stuff that I had never did but
as far as regretting like decisions and
stuff it wouldn't have led me here
and made me the person that I am I'm I
don't think I'm a mean person at all
you've lived a good life yeah yeah
you've done the things you wanted to do
yeah and they're for your kids and stuff
like that that's right my kids and my
grandbabies is my wife
emotionally what are you going through
struggle emotionally it's a struggle
It's gotta be
good
the fear of what you're gonna I watched
my mom my mom had Cohen Henson and I
watched her
suffer so bad and I'm afraid of that I
don't want that and I don't want my kids
to have to see what I've seen my mom go
through
and living here in Appalachia
tell me tell me what you what you see
going on around you a lot of people are
involved in drugs here and oh it's bad
yeah it's really bad here uh
some of the best hearted people
turn into drugs of that meth has came in
awful here
a lot of stealing
um people lying just
it's awful lot stuff I've never seen
before you go to everetts and when I was
little we didn't see homeless people in
Harlan County
and now that's all you see sometimes if
you drive early enough you'll see people
climbing out of the dumpsters it's
really sad is it difficult for you
you're going through what you're going
through with cancer
which was not a not something you chose
to do not something you got yourself
into it's just what happened to you
those are the cards you were dealt is it
difficult for you to go through that and
then watch these people that are oh
definitely just kind of deciding to
destroy their lives definitely yeah
sometimes I've wished I could Tom to the
tree and beat some sense into them
drugs it's
hit a couple people in close to me and
my family and it's uh it's a sad illness
to watch addiction is sad it's so sad
that this this part of the country has
so much of it yes like I said whenever I
was little you didn't see homeless
people and now you see them during the
day you see them sitting in front of the
stores outside charging their phones
they're getting ran off it's it's
pitiful why do you think there are so
many drugs no but why do you think
there's so many involved in drugs is it
because there's no jobs is because yeah
um used to mining was the only thing
here and now that the coal mines is tuck
out there's nothing here for these young
kids so I think they get mixed up in the
wrong crowds and turn to drugs
are you worried about your children
definitely
not so much my daughter my son
um he has seen it firsthand in our
community
um and he's totally turned against it
but um where he's going to be going to
high school next year he uh I'm scared
of him getting mixed in with the wrong
crowd and turning to drugs and I'm
scared if something happens to me don't
turn into drugs
yeah there's a girl who I
interviewed from
Clay County
who's in high school
I think she's just graduated
um and her entire family is involved in
drugs pretty heavily
and she saw that and decided to kind of
steer clear of all that and stay on the
right track and now she I think she's
going to nursing school and I think
she's getting married now yeah so I
think it's great sometimes being around
it
that's why I don't worry about my
daughters she's seen her dad and a few
other people in our family and
she's so turned against it she's going
to be 23 this year and she still talks
about how she don't like it so I'm I'm
not too much worried about her she seems
to have a good head on her shoulder
but my son I he's got so much faith that
um I'm gonna fight this and and be okay
and he prays for me constantly there was
one day he even said
asked me if I thought that it would do
any good if he prayed like every 15-20
minutes on trying to help me and uh I
told him that God's always listening but
he don't have to pray you know that
often unless he wants to talk to God
but I'm scared that if something happens
to me he'll lose that faith and turn the
drugs
are you worried at all about his father
and him inheriting some of those
personality traits
um yeah I really do but um me and my old
man we've worked hard to try to
put certain drill certain stuff in his
head and he's a good-hearted person so
and his his sperm donors will never get
out of prison so I I used to worry about
him getting out and catching them out in
the camp playing and just pick them up
and stuff but I don't worry about that
no more because I was told that he'll
never get out of jail
has your son met his father no when he
was uh maybe one or two
um Jason had left to go somewhere and I
think he was sort of watching for Jason
to leave because not too long after that
he come and he uh I tried not to let him
in but he pushed the door open and came
on in
and he was trying to take him outside
and I knew if he took him outside I
might not never see him so I wouldn't I
got my ball back and I wouldn't let him
do that but he don't remember that he uh
my son said that
he didn't know who that was but he seen
the devil in his eyes
my son was really afraid was crying and
everything of him after he left
um but um
I think that was it that was the last
time that he'd met him
where he don't remember he knows that I
got with Jason when he was a year old
and he calls Jason dad
but Jason's been here for him that is
his dad and he knows that Jason's his
stepdad that he's got another dad but he
don't know a whole lot about him
and Tabitha what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life in this this battle you're
going through now
follow your dreams if there's something
that you want to do do it
and be kind to people it don't take
nothing to be kind to people and help
people
all this hate in the world
we need love
beautiful Tabitha thank you so much for
sharing your story oh thank you for
listening I wish you all the luck in the
world thank you very much thank you very
much